الهدف المعلن لقرار وضع حد اقصى للسعر
بايعا نفط الروسي ضعف موسكو وحرمانها من
وسائل الاستمرار تمويل عمليتها العسكريه
في اوكرانيا ومن معقل اتخاذ القرارات
العقربيه ضد موسكو جاء الرد الروسي برفض
اعاده صياغه المبادئ الاساسيه للاسواق
الحره وتحذير من فرد اي سقف على صادرات اي
دوله لاسباب سياسيه واتهام الغرب بتهوره
في علاج المشاكل التي اثارها بنفسه كما
اعلنت موسكو بان الطلب على نفسها سيستمر
رغم القرار الغربي قرار تحديد سقف لسعر
النفط الروسيه زمن مع دخول حذر على والده
الروسيه عبر البحر اعتبارا من الاثنين
رئيسه المفاوضات الاوروبيه اعتبرت ان
الارادات النفطيات الروسيه ستتقلص واسعار
طاقه العالميه ستستقر لكنها رئيس مركز
تطوير طاقه الروسيه لديه نظره المعاكسه
حين اكد ان بلاده لن تابع نفطها السقف
اسعار التكتل صحيفه نيويورك تايم ذا اقللت
من التبعات السلبيه للقرار الاوروبي حيث
اعتبرت انه ما زال بامكاني موسكو جاني
ارباح كبيره بينما اعلنت اليابان انها
تتوقع اجراءات عقبيه من قبل روسيا بعد
القرار الغربي توقعات الخبراء ان تغير
روسيا مسار ضخ نفط نحو الشرق خصوصا الصين
والهند ليبقى التحدي امام الغرب تعويض حصه
روسيا من النفط الامر الذي سيدخل العالم
بازمه نفطن تضاف للغاز على حد قولهم حنان
المصري العربيه